[Music]
hello Louis hello this is more Eddie is
everything all right can I talk to you
about something
sure we both have been on our own for
years I'm lonely
and I'm guessing you might be too how
long have we known each other
oh we've been neighbors we don't really
know each other how about we get to know
each other I don't want anybody to think
anything bad you know how it is people
talk it's not about sex it's about
getting through the night I think I
could sleep again if there was somebody
next to me here Oh someone nice
[Music]
and now let's draw the merry way you
wake up one morning and you have
everything and the next morning that's
all God
where do we go to town that lunch sounds
fine to me maybe I'll wear something
bright and flashy why me I always
thought you were a good man to us so
good one maybe that's not a great way
[Music]
[Music]
some things we can't fix what should we
do about it
we could try talking what do you think
about that oh I think that's a good idea
never know what it might lead to
Shuler babe
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]